[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this is 360 packets hot cocoa mix
and this is a bathtub we just got done
with the eggnog ice bath challenge that
was a horrible experience so now we're
going to do something medley from anyway
so we got a 360 mix here we've got a
bunch of hot water at the ready
we've got multiple cans of whipped cream
to top it all off because frankly the
store didn't have enough marshmallows
they didn't have any at all but by some
freak incident after do we did the last
charity livestream they sent us not a
normal gift they sent us this many they
sent us this many cans of whipped cream
and they said hey you guys will probably
think of some way to use this and by
gosh we did so thank you crisis text
line and if you haven't seen it we're
going to be doing another charity
livestream right around the corner but
first we gotta get this started
so step one fill the bathtub in search
of a filling bathtub
step 2 break down all of these welcome
package into the bathtub insert shot of
us doing such things step 3
top it off with delightful whipped cream
insert shot of whipped cream here and
it's not just gonna be me I'm gonna be
assisted by my fellow elves I'm not a
mouth on the tree I know yeah your
elephant mouth so I felt why are you
sure this
[Music]
we just flex so I can't seem to bears
it's not really a challenge
[Music]
yes that is 360 packets of hot cocoa
powder in lukewarm bath water it's not
too pleasant to look at but it has not
been stirred yet so I got my stir at the
ready just to make it even more
disgusting so um before I'm gonna draw
like no oh that's nice it's a good
little smiley face on there is some
sweet oh is it tiny buckston yeah you do
look happy
oh he's not gonna be happy okay here we
go oh that feels weird
aw it feels so weird if you are
currently grossed out right so in the
comments below if you're a ghost
smash that like button 5 million likes
its ASMR bath time boo these [ __ ]
boulders of cocoa powders they look at
icebergs here we have no idea if visit
the proper ratio of hot cocoa to water
or whatever it is it doesn't seem like
there's enough water here so I might add
a gap that's like soggy cereal oh jeez
that's so [ __ ] gross I mean it feels
like water obviously we're just in the
chunky bits it's in phony which is just
bizarre
hey Bob either this is gonna lightful
and everyone who want to dip yeah
everyone will want to join us
in the bath of the disgusting hot cocoa
mix let me pass wait up oh yeah
[Music]
here Pasi that's hot cocoa all right
that's a nice cup of joe mm-hmm
now we're going to add the red crab and
that means a lot of creme let's don't
forget exploded out bomb through this
thing hang on I'm hitting the road
Rendell plan oh look at that we are a PG
channel for family and friends so we're
gonna have this whipped cream and it's
gonna be delightful for everybody
involved
okay everybody ready to make it colder
[Music]
three separate styles the swirls the
lines the spiral lovely alright as you
can see this may be the world's biggest
cup of hot chocolate it's not good it's
not pleasant but by all accounts it's
probably drinkable so I'm going to I'm
gonna test this up I've got a cup here
and I've got a strong stomach so I'm
just gonna mmm
that was cold that was just cold bottoms
up
[Music]
that is actually not bad right here we
got a long guy's dick first first tried
cheers Cheers
please ladies
I really is about that's pretty good
okay now in the stage - alright so you
may have been wondering this whole time
why we were in bathing suits and
shirtless it wasn't just for your
enjoyment and it wasn't just for us to
be comfortable in our own skin because
nobody should body shame us scars are
beautiful leave away you may have been
wondering but I will answer that
question right now
because I it was so weird it was like
penetrating a layer of cold and then
dipping into just moderately warm why
why did we need to get into this losing
the only reason to get into this we
could just we could have just made
because you made this in love of it do
you need a buddy you know what this is
the kind of thing that should be enjoyed
with friends so come on friends
[Music]
if you weren't high from the cocoa
powder you're pretty high right now
[Music]
would you like to clink oh of course
clink ease Merry Christmas market
Merry Christmas my good friends there
you go Merry Christmas
give me something makes your skin very
smooth like that it is hard it's very
hot um this is uh this is this is an
example of ideas that should never come
to light where I there we go there we go
I hope you guys are thoroughly disgusted
but remember we did this for you guys
and we did this because no one's
stopping us so don't act surprised
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you Ethan and Tyler for
helping me out this way with this I
don't know why you did what you did and
I'm proud of you guys what if this was
Ison what if this was our job thank you
everybody so much for watching let us
know what you think of this and if you
try this at home don't we'll stop you
before you do just don't not worth it
won't stay warm and oddly enough it's
very uncomfortable so thank you
everybody so much for joining us and as
always we'll see you
[Music]
[Applause]